speaking of winners this guy's on the
Mount Rushmore of around the horn great
hair great columnist
he's Tim Kalman Shaw and in that order
by the way great hair great columnist
Tim Calvin show Dallas Morning News and
around the horn hi Tim that's key and
television is it back down yeah and you
know our you know you know the living
embodiment of that I'd like to think so
absolutely I give more thought to my
hair than I do the content of this
program what is the local reaction to
Jerry Jones fighting the Commissioner
fighting the league and fighting for
Ezekiel Elliott I think people are on
his side in terms of you know is there
some way to take down the evil Goodell
go get him Jerry that's that sort of
attitude beyond that I don't think
there's really a much of an
understanding because he hasn't said
anything publicly about what he's doing
or why he's doing it so there's a lot of
guesswork involved now clearly this is
some kind of reaction to what happened
with Zeke and he tries to pretend it's
not yeah but I mean it is so it's just
established that it is and my thought is
you know Goodell's Jerry's right about
the contract why pay the guy 49 million
ago she gets I get that part but I don't
get going to war relatively speaking
suing owners hiring high-powered
attorneys to do all that over over that
I would think that sounds more like
something you do when you're trying to
take it up a notch
and get somebody eventually out of
office
Ezekiel Elliott if he'd had taken the
suspension at the start of the season
would would how would he have been
viewed as far as in the court of public
opinion if he did it without any fight I
mean that's a fair question and that's
the only the only thing I mean I wrote
and I said I think he should take the
suspension at the start of the season
take the six games get this behind him
don't drag it on you know we had the
brady scenario it could go into 2018
just be the running back who's going
after the league's the first for two
years of your career and acknowledged
and I said just say the things they said
in their release yesterday was pretty
much what I said say this is not an
admission of guilt we don't agree with
this but for the good of me good of the
team good of everybody involved we're
gonna we're gonna go ahead and you know
the fact we're not going to win because
it's stacked against us we're gonna go
ahead and take this penalty and from a
team standpoint I don't think they would
have gone worse
three and three without input just what
they went with him and they would have
had a better structure in terms of all
right we're not going to have our guy
for six games but then we'll have him
for the last ten instead they had this
up and down is it going to be here it's
not they lost in two days before the
Falcons game and they played a terrible
game at Atlanta and now you're you don't
have him for stretch run until there's
two games left to go but your point is
good in that if he doesn't find it at
all does it look like an admission of
guilt and and I guess if you're in that
position you feel like I've got to fight
this for a while we're talking to Tim
Couch on Dallas Morning News and of
course the star of around the horn when
you start to look and now we've almost
itemized this with the Cowboys like
who's the most valuable cowboy is it
Shawn Lee is it Ezekiel Elliott it's a
dak Prescott or is it
tyronn Smith I'm starting to think it's
a left tackle you know I don't care what
anybody else does if you can't block the
guy and he's gonna get to the
quarterback and disrupt everything he
might be more valuable to all these
Cowboys is he gonna play against the
Eagles they think he might suddenly will
not obviously Zeke will not but you're
right I mean watching that game Sunday
Tyron Smith went from maybe five or six
on everybody's list right to right to
number one yeah because six-packs and
it's not you know it's not six facts
from JJ Watt or Khalil knack it's it's a
guy who had two sacks in the first eight
games and was a fairly inexpensive free
agent signing in the offseason so yeah I
mean he they got to have him now that
was a that was a disaster
and here's the question oh I have one
for you they play Philadelphia Sunday
all right Cowboys would like to think
that's a big game but realistically the
Cowboys trying to make the wild card
they got a place again in four days they
got to play Joey Bosa on Thursday do you
save time on Smith kind of mmm not punt
this game but acknowledged they have
three winnable games after this charges
at home Redskins at home at the Giants
they need to win all three of those
games there's already kind of an
assumption they may not win Sunday night
and that's a Sunday night the Thursday
afternoon turnaround for a guy with a
bad back that groin well the Cowboys
make the playoffs I would say right now
no I do think they have a chance because
but you got to get to ten and six you
can't you can't sneak in at night and
seventies you look at Carolina at seven
and three and you look at Seattle at six
and three although Seattle's beat the
hell then you got some good five four
teams and you know about the Lions with
their easy schedule so you got to get to
ten and six and this team is probably
going to be five and five after Sunday
night so 30% maybe 25% chance they make
I'm still fascinated with Jerry Jones I
think that he you know the league was an
enabler with him they allowed him to do
a lot of things because he made some
things happen and now all of a sudden
you say - Jerry hey you're not running
this league and Jerry's probably saying
right back to him I have been told you
before that you know they put him in the
Hall of Fame for making money it's a
very odd thing to put somebody in the
Hall of Fame for yeah you made rich guys
just filthy richer way to go but yeah I
mean he's not going quietly at 75 and
with a gold jacket he's not going to
just go off into the sunset so it's hard
to that's why I think I mean this can't
just be simply I don't like the looks of
Roger Goodell's contract it needs to be
more incentive based I think that's
starting point and I think he's ready
for a bigger fight than that is he good
for the Cowboys Jerry yeah I've always
you know yes in an entertainment way
it's very hard to say he is well this is
20 second straight year without going to
the NFC Championship if that happens it
looks like that happens and you know we
can all say he was the GM when Jimmy
Johnson was here but we all know though
it's crap and there's that that's been a
constant stain I mean you look at the
the winningest teams of the decade or a
decade of the century they're not in the
top ten I mean they're not there's
nothing great about the team except the
brand now if you want to give him credit
for the brand and the stadium and all
that he plays a big part of that and
they're the most talked about five and
four team in the league this week and
they will be the most talked about five
and five team in the league next
something that standpoint is great no
it's not no it's not and it almost felt
like this year was dak Prescott it
became his team because we had the
uncertainty in the preseason last year
with Tony Romo where he sort of
inherited the job and we didn't know how
good he was and then people are
surprised at how good he was now we know
how good he is and it's become his team
even more so now with dak Prescott not
being in there do you see this as it's
more of a passing team it's more DAX
team than it is a Zeke Elliott led team
I mean it a little more but not a lot
more throwing a lot more that's not
going to work I don't think I think I
think dak has decent receivers I don't
think he has great receivers I don't
think anybody puts Dez in the top ten
many more wide receivers Witten's had a
great career but he's not top seven or
eight tight ends at the moment but that
he has okay receivers but first of all
they got to block the pass rush the
you get sacked eight times again so they
they you know I think they can run the
ball better than they did Sunday I give
some of these defenses but some of them
they won't and Sunday night they may not
the Eagles may just completely shut it
down and then then they're stuck with
just throwing it and that that could get
ugly Jim it's great to talk to you and
good luck with the next appearance on
around the horn I gotta go work on my
hair are you won today no I know I just
mean in kind of a general way I do three
hours of local radio but I like to do it
with good do you wear makeup
why would do you wear makeup when you do
radio not when I sleep when I do radio
no okay
no I do have but here's the thing I have
makeup for round the horns as they sent
me and I go by from time to time I don't
really know how to put it on and I'm
like woody I don't have somebody sitting
there putting it on for me putting a big
towel big thing over me big sheet
applying it so I do it myself
and about halfway through the show
during the commercial they'll go Tim
spray the infield and I just know that
means do something with something and I
just had some more makeup on and try to
get through the show well they're using
a little secret there spackling woody
though that's the difference though well
thank you Tim for your insights we
appreciate it and have a good rest of
the afternoon
thank you that's Tim Couch all around
the one Dallas Morning News for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
you